[Music]
when we started studying people paying
their taxes we were kind of looking for
a real pain point that people have if
you think about what's the worst day of
the year for you often the worst day of
the year is when you have to write that
extra check to the IRS and of course
it's partly we hate it just because we
have to give money away that we wish we
could keep but we thought there might be
some other underlying psychology going
on for why we hate paying taxes so much
and if you think about it when you send
that check off you kind of have no idea
what happens with it I mean you know
it's going to your state or federal
government but you don't really know
what it's being used for you look
outside and you see roads and there's
some link between those in some way or
another but you don't really know
exactly what's happening and that
decoupling between what you're sending
in and what the output is is actually
pretty aversive for us we kind of like
to know when we do something what's
going to happen as a result and so what
we try to do in our research is wreak
uppal those two things closer together
so imagine for example when you paid
your taxes you write in the amount and
then you can allocate where you want
things to go you could actually say I
want more of my taxes to go to schools
versus roads versus the military or the
reverse if you wanted to support the
military more and the idea there was
sure we still wouldn't like paying taxes
that much because we wish we could spend
our money on ourselves but recup lling
the cost and the benefits might actually
help us hate it a little bit less we've
talked to a lot of governments local
government state governments federal
governments in the US and around the
world about implementing this idea of
recouping
tax payments with the benefits that
citizens get politically it's quite
difficult so you can imagine that if you
talk about letting citizens allocate all
of their money wherever they want you
might not get funding for really basic
things like infrastructure that aren't
really that exciting for people to think
about so politically there's a real risk
to kind of opening up democracy where
instead of taxes going into a pool where
elected officials decide what needs to
be done each individual citizen has a
voice one way we've tried to deal with
that is to think about maybe you don't
need to allocate a hundred percent of
your taxes wherever you want but what if
I said at the end of the year you know
what you're going to
to allocate 10% wherever you want so
most of your taxes are still going to be
the old way where they go into a general
pool and then the people we've elected
who we in theory trust will decide where
the money goes
but we still as citizens get to say a
little bit more about what we want to do
and some City of the United States have
started doing this through something
called participatory budgeting and the
idea there is that a city can take some
tax money it could be a small amount it
could be a large amount the city of
Cambridge where I live has done this and
let citizens vote for where that money
should go so they're not getting access
to all of the tax revenue for the entire
city but the city is saying we want to
set aside some money where citizens can
actually tell us where it should go and
we will follow through and make sure the
money goes there and again that helps
citizens see that there
it's called participatory budgeting
they're actually participating and
getting to make specific decisions about
what happens with their taxes one of the
things that we've thought about is taxes
are big so if you think about changing
the entire tax system that can be
politically difficult it sort of changes
the nature of the relationship between
our money and the federal government but
you can think about smaller sort of
initiatives where it's not the entire
tax revenue for a city or for a country
but imagine my my colleague Kate
Lamberton at Pittsburgh has shown for
example that if you can allocate your
parking fines so you get a ticket on
your car and you're furious because of
course you parked in the right place and
it's you know unjust that you will never
get a ticket what if even just on that
parking ticket could be 25 or 50 dollars
even there you might be able to say just
a little bit on the margin I'd like this
fee to go to this in my city instead of
that in my city now you're not changing
kind of the whole political system
around taxation but you're still
changing the relationship between
citizens and government on a real pain
point which is of course paying fees and
fines that you incurred but I can now
sort of tell the city yeah it's true I
parked in the wrong place and I will pay
you but I'll give you a little voice in
where that money goes and I might feel a
little bit better about paying that
[Music]
you